alors richard tu es connu pour ses coups
de gueule et coups de tête et coups de
coeur 1 c'est bien ça non j'ai de faire
une interview dernier coup ouais tu mens
jamais eu c'est le regard au dernier
coup de gueule justement face à ce qu'il
ya cinq minutes
maintenant si je vais pas répondre tout
le temps à ta place
qu'est ce que tu veux je te dis ton
dernier coup de gueule dans la vie voilà
non il la pense mon un bon nom mon
profil bas profil bas mais volontaire
ouais difficile je connais divisible en
face à man dernier coup de coeur les
confessions d'un par jour
ouais dans les coups de poing
il ya deux ans ouais ouais qu'entre qui
bat eu un mec
enfin c'est d'ailleurs c'était pas
volontaire il s'agit d'essayer de se
raccrocher
et il a glissé et que j'étais cuit on a
été déclarée matches nuls oui de dans la
sueur les clubs avec le torch
c'est vachement bien il y avait un
berger allemand dans les cieux au
dernier coup de foudre et coup de foudre
ouais ma fille dernier coup de rouge il
ya 14 mois à 14 mois la flotte
ouais t'as mais rien ça te va bien merci
ça et la coupe de cheveux non mais c'est
vrai assez fort mais on serait pas en
public la dernier coup de rein
gourin
quelques jours ouais bah c'est pas tous
les jours non et quand même jour deux
jours à mousson ouais c'est quoi trois
fois par semaine ouais ben voilà on est
au courant comme ça d'un coup de bluff
que tu as fait à fretin ce fut tellement
en dérapage au contrôle et là j'ai
inscrit le nom des mecs que je voulais
dans mon film avant de leur avoir
demandé
ouais ouais du coup ils ont été obligés
d'accepter tapis ministre c'est du bluff
pour toi ben alors il faut laisser faire
son trou et moi j'en sais rien moi toute
façon qu'ils jugeaient tout et c'est
caramba ouais c'est kalamba tout ça non
étape il faut le laisser bosser
bon faudra bien arriver je vais te faire
une interview dernier coup hockey dans
les coups de coeur mon dernier coup de
coeur bat et remonte déjà à quelques pas
mal d'années moi je continue
oui l'année coup-de-poing mon dernier
coup de poing c'était à gstaad
il y avait un temps un type qui m'a
traitée de sale français toute l'année
coup de folie
dernier coup de folie basse et quand je
m'achète geste n'avait cependant ça ça
ne goûte pas trois mais bayonne
lamborghini
pour l'instant c'est
une mercedes 300 sl trois là je sais
bien ouais je taperai dernier coup de
gueule au le dernier coup de gueule
c'est après moi même je crois cette
année contre moi que j'ai je veux aussi
faire le plus c'est dur avec moi même je
suis dur avec moi même pas donc pas ce
que je n'aime pas tellement et je me
fais chier je m'auto fait chier tu
comprends la défaite du rc east a cassé
l'année coup dur dernier coup dur ça
c'est une histoire j'aime mieux pas
parler d'en face a été l'un avec moi de
ma fille on n'en parle pas non l'un des
coups de soleil pas le dernier coup de
soleil je suis passé récent gta grâce à
quelques temps vous souhaitez bien m'a
fait bien à bronzer
whissell bronzage du riche pourquoi le
riche tu crois que les gars qui
travaillent sur le hot 100 pap aux
blacks ou beurs un dernier coup de bol
ça jamais sans arrêt et je veux pas
faire chier les autres un public jeune
et non pas de remords il encore que les
autres ne le soit pas les siens dernier
coup de rein ben j'ai encore des blues
ça je peux pas alors les coups de blues
ça fait partie c'est où tous les jours
pendant un moment un moment tous les
jours comme il faut par sa dépendance
est il mort des périodes bien des
périodes où c'est cool ça vraiment le
zoo a oui et puis d'autres où ça cette
tombe sur la gueule comme ça mais
heureusement je suis bien entouré je
bosse le boulot c'est merveilleux ton
père qui m'avait dit ça il m'a dit tu ne
trouveras que deux choses dans la vie
que deux choses valables c'est le
travail et l'amour et tu peux pas
trouver autre chose d'abord tourné comme
tu veux l'amour sous toutes ses formes
maternelle filiales
amour bien sûr avant tout et puis le
boulot la joie de travailler la joie
d'en avoir les fruits et du cac ton père
avait raison
oui tout à fait quand y'a le jingle
parce qu'on met le titre et tout ça il
faut pas bouger parce que sinon ça
oblige à figer l'image donc
[Applaudissements]
et voilà c'est pas beau ça cela m'amuse
c'est un truc pour s'amarrer moi c'est
pas compris comment décrire ce que je
ressens bouge pas et ça évite de le
figer l'image en régie je veux dire ça
gagne bien quand bon vous êtes prête
oui bon alors dernier coup un votre
dernier coup dur
dernier coup dur des histoires de
personnel de par rapport à mes enfants
auxquels je tiens enfin qui sont mes
compagnons de vie quoi heureusement du
désert
donc voilà des deux choses de ma vie
j'étais malade
non non je dirais pas parlé je peux en
parler par rapport à ses jours et celle
des piscines on me dit on se bagarre
pour ça non le dernier coup de tête
téléphoner un copain j'ai pas l'ami ne
suis pas 3 à 3 heures du mat non et oui
non mais je devrai dormi à lui disant on
vient dire non non non non ah bon ce
mail par un coup de tête
maintenant j'ai l'esprit mal tourné
si c'est comme ça je le sais dernier
coup de foudre d'un rapport à un homme
mais malheureusement alors cette façon
tu n'es pas bon non ben on m'a lancé un
appel non merci je vois comme manager
donc j'ai pas confiance avec un numéro
vert non
en quoi votre père vous en gamme si vous
notez que failli me regarde les éditions
arrêtés lors plus c'est très bien que
j'aime bien avec maman aussi maman âgée
discret tout ça mais mais mais il m'a
dit oui tu comprends ça il n'est pas je
parle trop et maintenant il sait que je
porte ce sens bah oui il n'ya pas que
les gros mots des trucs plutôt jusque là
où jusque là elle s'est bien comportée
merde alors là j'ai michel dotta michel
cathala milles de là me dieudonné thiery
franchement t'aime bien mais là tu
exagères voilà la wii dont votre père
qui était journaliste sur leurs terres
faut bien le dire absolument être
pouvoir était rock et en afrique en plus
tard dakar votre père si si je suis né
je suis appliqué à dakar je fais meriem
je connais tous deux vous ne vous avons
pas me raconter d'histoires mois bon
dernier coup de rein de rein devra donc
l'amour hier a alors assuré que j'espère
que monsieur célarié rassurer dans quels
cas pas oui papa et bien sûr et papa
parce que sa fille
donc c'était pas avec le dernier coup de
foudre s'était c'est symbolique mais
c'est pas un coup de foudre
excusez moi je comprends la non mais je
les aime beaucoup mais je sais coup de
foudre
ah ouais d'accord sur le coup draft avec
un copain non ça devient bon moi j'ai
les coûts de foot je sais pas trop parce
que moi je tombe souvent mais amoureux
est forcément doc je veux dire je sais
ce que je dis [__]
maintenant vous êtes mieux quand vous
faites pas attention à ce que vous dites
quand je parle des hommes ça se retourne
contre moi ce n'est pas une vie c'est
vrai classique et que les gens vous
l'aurez vous et 42 ans je ne suis pas
mariée je ne suis pas installé dans une
vie mais c'est comme ça j'ai plus rien
et puis ya plein d'autres femmes comme
ça et puis et puis crottes
regardez les flux mais bon voilà non
mais c'est non mais oui non mais elle
est très jeune et n'a pas quarante deux
heures ce n'est pas 40 cm s'est
plusieurs fois sur le bistouri
c'est tout donc après on vous peut être
eu et puis vous avez des articles dit
n'importe quoi cherche d'ailleurs pas
des trucs c'est pour ça c'est zé
maintenant il n'y a pas assez de temps
pour en parler pour que ce soit vers
découdra on va en rester là c'était hier
soir oui mais un coup de rein pour moi
c'est de l'amour ces deux là c'est pas
du sahb est non oui c'est de l'amour
mais l'amour pour moi le sexe et d'amour
dedans franchement ça ne m'intéresse pas
du tout d'accord avis aux amateurs n'ont
été rallumé les lumières de pt a de
l'air très chaud en rouge
[Musique]
où l'on atteint le dernier coup ou
dernier coup de tête
dernier coup de tête le coup de tête
c'est en partant peut-être aurait de la
télé ouais les coups de poing mon mari
l'an dernier coup de poing c'est plutôt
une engueulade en voiture
ah ouais voilà avec larusso
tiens d'ailleurs je vais dire en parlant
de larusso va lancer un appel fallait
pour chercher un jules tout ça on a
lancé un appel dans l'émission ça a
super bien marché
personne danic houdrouge en famille pour
les 20 ans de ma soeur c'est quand même
temps c'était le 19 janvier oh la vache
à lait comment vois tu sers à 81 1 m 80
je peux pas moi ça me complexe du
complexe du petit gros mois quand c'est
terrible drew gooden danic pas de fuite
s'était pas de fuite beaucoup d un petit
oui on voit quand même j'ai dit à didier
sonné c'est mon choix demain notamment
par josy de montfavet de la bouche rouge
et or rien là où c'est au bord des
routes bluff non je suis très mauvaise
même au poker je suis pas venu pas vrai
ouais et on amour tout ça vous ne le
fait jamais non là du pot ce goal nom
est bizarre comme phrase
vers les coups de chapeau s'est conclue
question possède d'après mieux
je vous demande de ne pas répondre
franchement c'est imbécile la suivante
et mieux dernier coup de rein mais vous
avez déjà été mieux
hier david o je comprends pourquoi ils
perdent toujours dans les coups de blues
[Musique]
ça bougeait ainsi ouais j'ai un peu
bougeant calcul à tes trucs quand je
suis à votre avis sur vous l'avez fait
mais c'est avec ces voiles ont refusé
d'entrer tué dernier coup à vous dernier
coup dur la mort de mon manager c'est
pas ça n'a rien à voir le truc je suis
mort de rire
adriana c'est pas ça can you please
trois ans late for the girl produits ont
traduit très bien la nature la pause
dans les coups de tête dernière voiture
que pendant ma dernière voiture c'est
quoi je veux faire la pub je les payais
quand même jeu gratuite
une fois qu une voiture que le monde
entier connaît la fois fait pas de
voiture
parmi ces jeunes secondes en fait c'est
une berline un peu confortable
c'est un beau char bombe au charbon bien
mes coups de coeur
sekkaki quelqu'un qui dit qu'il me relis
tes de seattle d'ailleurs roger beauvais
josé bové josé bon dernier coup de coeur
alors dernier coup de coeur qui me reste
pas mal oui vous allez vous marier ccj
peut-être sa gonzesse attacks of
congress et kimberley et seattle déçu
cette motion
henri suivre
dernier coup de bluff bluff kimberley
[Rires]
rigole attend dernier coup de rein elle
est partie quelques semaines quelques
semaines déjà c'est un petit peu à cran
puisqu'ils très bon ben alors avis aux
amatrices
il est chaud le garçon régime
[Musique]
non
bien intervenu dernier coup votre
dernier coup dur j'en ai pas je me
rappelle pas non je pense frêche aurait
perdu la mémoire avec tout ça non ouais
je profiterai peu très peu de noirs way
votre dernier coup de tête j'ai un htc
dont vous n'êtes pas avec les flics je
vous rappelle demande en chine ont
réservé n'ont rien du tout bon
dernier coup de coeur ma femme et puis
ma petite fille dernier coup de poing
donné coup de poing alors si c'est bon
j'ai c'est sur un ring dans la vie tu en
joues en feu bien non je crois que
c'était dans la vie mais ont tous été
beaucoup pensent qu'une claque hommes se
valent c'est sympa c'est infectueuses
dernier coup de gueule il n'ya pas
longtemps à ya pas longtemps on m'a
enlevé ma voiture dans une dans la fois
hier mouvement voiture et il fut élaboré
il ya des mecs qui tous attaqué ce
[Rires]
dernier coup de rouge
dernier coup de rouge bon à l'âge avant
de descendre ouais otage une jolie peau
douce ne sont pas là pareil bien les
coups de poker à las vegas avec quand
vous jouez au poker à las vegas derniers
coups de feu non non non jamais dire
jamais non je t'ai riquet sa voix la
sincérité journal en même temps dans les
coups de blues d'un écoute blues
gros coup de blues quand j'ai perdu mon
argent ouais 10 millions de recettes ça
énerve dernier coup de rein pour
longtemps hier soir et ce matin
non j'ai pas le temps cet après midi
devant moi j'ai pas le temps ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dernier coup dur le dernier coup dur la
candidature de balladur alors it will
avait déjà 3 et wii dernier coup de
coeur dernier coup de coeur pour
l'interview de françoise de panafieu
dans l ouais
qui dit quoi parle dit beaucoup de
choses et l andi et sa famille andy
aussi il ya une chose qui m'a intéressé
c'est que sa soeur dit quand elle était
petite
il ya eu une grande famille cette
famille de sept frères et soeurs je
crois que sept ou huit
et elle était là glee n'est donc a été
la reine ouais et nous étions ses
esclaves et on lui apportait le savons
les chaussons autres donc ça va ça m'a
vraiment intéressé un peu peut-être
aussi inquiété pas rouler mais canal
face ici très bien
dernier coup de poing d'un collaborateur
qui suit déjà manqué de respect comme
étant un peu un peu loin de mes
préoccupations politiques au delà
dernier coup de folie elle s'ouvre le
soutien permanent à jean tiberi
ouais dernier coup de foudre françoise
de panafieu bernadette chirac bernadette
chirac
j'aurais pas de toile avec votre femme
vous mois dernier coup de gueule alors
ça le dernier coup violent c'est
permanent
ouais mais cécilia c'était il ya une
heure et demie et les méchants soit pas
qui ressemble à un tollé en trois un peu
bled il faut savoir si ces raspoutine
richelieu sarah un napoléon iii
physiquement franchement c'est juste
aller plutôt lensois badinguet et vous
savez que ce gars est fair livres sur
napoléon iii je suis beaucoup napoléon
iii je sais bien que c'était un grand
empereur voilà dernier coup de pub
bassila c'est vraiment elle vous aide
pas beaucoup mais non mais c'est bien
parce que je trouve que c'est quelqu'un
qui dit ce qu'elle pense elle qui
aimante qui est vrai c'est bien car est
plus beau que la sincérité de mon
dernier coup c'est fini c'est fini
dernier coup de rouge eh ben c'est ya
deux heures
oui vous avez branché tout cas les faits
la cave de l'hôtel de ville nantes j'ai
fait la cave de l'hôtel de ville
ouais quand même cette bouteille 500
sénat 15 mille bouteilles quinze mille
bouteilles mesdames messieurs et je suis
sur le terrain
le puissant qui colle et ça me surprend
pas bon d'aller coup de chapeau
le mon dernier coup de chapeau c'est
celui que j'ai donné à jean tiberi
encore à sa sortie de l'hôpital parce
que ça correspondait à ce moment là une
campagne de presse
extravagante et je trouve que le courage
qui est manifeste en permanence mérite
un vrai coup de chapeau
dernier coup de poker c'est celui qu'on
joue en ce moment c'est la partie en jeu
cependant c'est celui-là niveau de poker
et pour finir dernier coup de rein
avant-hier à des revues merci je vais
regarder le match mercredi soir
cadets bordeaux ouais pour millas énorme
un moment très rare ces timbres dans les
prolongations étaient géniales unix sait
jamais dans le football c'est une
interview dernier coup chanter
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
donc c'est me répondre en chantant je
vous dis par exemple dernier coup dur
c'est sympa à faire j'ai quand même dit
voilà ça
jamais une fille qui était vraiment
jolie mais elle est partie avec mon
meilleur ami très bien mais aussi des
classeurs parce que c'est pas loin
d'être joué dernier coup de tête
j'émets une autre fille renouvelle j'ai
tout donné j'ai tout laissé j'ai tout
laissé tomber
et puis maintenant je perds la tête bien
mes coups de poing mon meilleur ami
j'ai fait le bois ensuite je lui ai mis
une droite dans sa gueule et il est
tombé
il a fallu l'hospitaliser c'est une
sorte de piccoli musicale en fait
dernier coup de foudre
j'ai rencontré une autre fille mais
celle là elle avait un chemisier rose
elle voulait savoir quelle était mon âge
elle s'est trompée mais peu importe car
je crois qu'ils se passe quelque chose
entre nous je démissionne dernière
question
dany brillant dernier coup droit c'est
tout à l'heure vous ai pas vues sur nous
les coudes dans la main on va le voir je
vais soigner laëtitia mais vous venez
d'aix la wii 2 nex
vous êtes venus pour l'émission fait pas
exprès non vous êtes venu pourquoi
parler pour voir une amie ah bon et
quand vous êtes retrouvé ici
quel est votre numéro de portable alors
comme votre livre vous dites que c'est
un coup de gueule on va vous faire une
interview dernier coup on ne bouge pas
d'un jingle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour
bien alors dernier coup de gueule
le dernier coup de gueule que j'ai
poussé c'était hier
contre qui c'était à propos de la sphère
rezala d'accord dernier coup de tête
dernier coup de tête qu'est ce que c'est
qu'un coup de tête j'ai un truc une
décision qu'on prend comme ça comme
cannes il veut rentrer avec emma stone
comme les maquis ventre avec kad dernier
se montent à des coups de tête c'était
il ya il ya quinze jours quand j'ai
acheté à ma fille des double rideau un
sac à dos de chez moi j'espère que ma
fille n'est pas sage est pensé pour
séduire une clientèle folle non elle
voulait un sac dans une boutique avec
elle elle a 11 ans 1
et elle me dit papa ce sac me plaît et
coûter cher ça marche ça m'a fait chier
de dépenser une somme attentes pour
livrer son sac mais j'ai pas pu lui
refuser c'est bien ben c'est bien ça
part d'un bon sentiment
un dernier coup de poing dans les coups
de poing c'était un vrai couteau à steak
et un jour ce pas le dire et pourquoi
dans ce quelqu'un qui a fait une
réflexion des images on sentait pas bien
il dépend des coûts dans un petit moment
présent dernier coup de pub
dernier coup de pub ce 6e soirée merci
parce que ça vaut vraiment la peine le
dernier coup de foudre dans les coups de
foudre
oui de foudre qu'est ce qu'ils disent
tous ma famille il aurait sûrement plu
c'est vrai moi vous êtes marrants les
mecs en plus c'est ma femme pour ces
grosses et moi j'ai pas trois mois mégi
120 que moi c'est ma femme
donc c'est bon dernier coup de bluff le
dernier coup de bluff tous les jours au
soir à metz après midi ouais avait dit à
l'audience mais à l'audience vrai débat
oui c'est votre boulot vous en même
temps mon boulot voilà dernier coup de
barre à bas tous les jours un dernier
coup de rein pour finir hier soir bravo
[Applaudissements]
je serai bush père de bush en la bouche
pas à le voir
les babouches pendant le dîner l
interview dernier coup geneviève de
fontenay a tendance à consommer comme
deezer
[Applaudissements]
bien geneviève dernier coup dur si tu
réponds un sacré il va te dire dernier
coucou
c'est ce que tu veux mais si on arrêtait
blindés non dernier coup dur pourrait
sérieusement au dernier coup dur votre
dernier coup dur moi mon oeil oui ça va
être très bien que c'est bien voilà je
ne vienne n'a pas de coup dur dernier
coup de tête à temps voilà exactement
des coups de coeur bayer a pris en
compte une petite appréhension
salut à rester et c'est une cession du
groupe de deauville nous avons rappel ça
fait plaisir de nous avons suffisamment
apporter un peu de joie à des enfants
trisomiques qui regardent et miss france
avec beaucoup d'émotion il y en a plein
les autres armoires dernier coup de
foudre c'est vous cher chuck dans le
dinner
[Musique]
on
dès que ma fille est plus là voilà je
constate que cette personne bouge merci
ça me fait très plaisir et je tiens
beaucoup à ça alors dernier coup c'est
facile dernier coup dur tandis que goody
en accident de voiture l'accident vers
les coups de coeur coups de coeur
adriana karembeu je comprends le dernier
dernier passait il ya cinq minutes du
coup qu'on vous avait bien dans les
coups de poing dernier coup de poing le
procès ouais dans des coups de folie
dernier coup de folie un très joli
cadeau pour maman dernier coup de foudre
dernier coup de foudre obama petit
partenaire maintenant landowski à huy
fab bien les coups de gueule dernier
coup de gueule je veux qu'on m'écoute
aux répétitions
ah oui je veux travailler alors il veut
répéter je trouve qu'on passe trop de
temps sur les autres passez sur moi bien
les coups de bluff dernier coup de bluff
quand est-ce que je peux le faire je
bluffe tout le temps mais souffre la
sauve ce soir là pouvaient pas essayer
un dernier coup de barre dernier coup de
barre c'était ce matin à 10h30
j'étais accroché à la barre ah oui
dernier avec lui c'est normal
bienvenue coup de blues
dernier coup de blues oh la la
yaba ya deux jours je rentre à la maison
crevé il était minuit et demi je mets la
radio évidemment c'est barbara qui
chante l'aigle noir chez du niagara
ça m'est arrivé avec lara fabian main
[Applaudissements]
bien des coups de poker dernier coup de
poker je serais tenté de dire le procès
aussi parce qu'on sait jamais si on va
gagner ou perdre heureusement or là
c'est la justice qui a gagné donc temps
mais attention patrick dupond dernier
couvre un dernier coup de rein
pas plus tard qu'avant-hier soir ça
s'est bien passé
or génial votre dernier coup dur pour le
baril sous les jours aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on va maintenant voilà il
d'irlandais de vincennes vingt ans après
un pas une claque pas une forme de
cachets une affaire internationale
vraiment on se demande pourquoi on vous
le reproche regardez cet homme un mec
quand même pas amener les armes chez moi
j'ai un peu peur quand il a dit votre
dernier coup dur et qui m'a montré
heureusement qu'à des témoins le dernier
coup de tête paul peut-être le livre est
pas mal
votre dernier coup de coeur le rwanda
pourquoi parce que c'est un c'est un
pays qui voue d'abord il ya eu 3
millions de morts je pense en quelques
temps et ça a été la plus grande
manipulation historique où on a fait
croire qu'un qu'une ethnie avaient
massacré une autre ethnie alors s non
celle inverse dans les coups de poing la
semaine dernière avec qui le soir non
mais ça c'est une affaire privée
ou alors c'est à dire le rendait encore
non non non c'est non non il me
regardait pas quand vous parlez de coups
de poing des coups de tête ils
m'inquiètent capitelles dans les coups
de foudre
dernier coup de foudre c'est difficile
ça vous n'êtes pas avec votre non pas
deux derniers coups de foudre
je voulais pas le dire non c'est normal
ouais ça se garde bien des coups de
gueule il ya une semaine avant le coup
d'envoi
non non avec mon équipe sera un problème
africain et une mission à l'extérieur
parce que je crois que quand on a on est
manager dans le privé on a une
organisation civile
mais quand même à caractère militaire et
le chef il garde une vieille notion
peut-être ça c'est important pour vous
qui voulez greffer des choses pour moi
le chef c'est celui qui crie le plus
fort qui frappe le plus fort et c'est
celui qui se fait respecter non mais ça
va avec le côté également intellectuelle
mais sur le terrain ça se passe comme ça
un air 1000 r je suis sûr mais non mais
non mais je pense c'est pour vous at on
déjà pour vous baril s'est elle même
s'est il agi story je voudrais vous dire
aussi baril si je voudrais vous dire
quand même que le courage moral beaucoup
d'hommes politiques que l'on mais moi le
courage moral va avec le courage
physique 1 et certains ont beaucoup de
courage moral mais de courage physique
ya pas grand chose ça bête et sega ou de
vous devez intervenir vous devez greffer
une puce de téléphone et que pour les
échos un pentium de courage physique est
ce que je sais un autre monde
je pourrais simplement dire c'est que
c'est un personnage historique après mon
capitaine
mais ce qui était un personnage
historique ce je trouve que je ne doute
pas de votre courage physique puisque je
connais un petit peu quand même votre
carrière
mais vous avez le sans doute l'âge
venant intégrer de du maintien de
l'ordre tout ce qui est pire c'est pas
la seule chose que j'ai intégré
c'est à dire l'idée est justement de la
force appliquée la loi
l'idée que grosso modo vous êtes là en
position de supérieur s'ils n'ont pas du
tout quoi non je voudrais vous dire une
chose vraiment né nombreux il ya des
dames qui sont ici le premier problème
qu'est ce que vous voulez tous vous
voulez tous cas sécurité voulaient
sortir tranquille voulait vivre
tranquillement
vous aimez pas la sécurité vous avez
retrouvé votre voiture ne s'est pas
terrifiant vous voulez harry leur des
ventes message politique mais tout le
monde veut ça aujourd'hui mais un an
quel prix on peut d'abord venu c'est en
moulinant placé en sortant ce soir 20h
gratuit
en motivant votre portefeuille vous
allez dire merci non j'appellerais la
police dans sept métiers vous a vécu
plus longtemps d'une l'appellerait la
police républicaine qui a hausse mais je
suis fière de voir monsieur barils
et je trouve terrible
c'est nathalie ces discussions là on a
besoin non mais je trouve ça formidable
je croyais qu aujourd'hui la police
était définitivement républicaine
qu'elle comprenait que pour faire
appliquer la loi il faut l'appliquer à
soi-même monsieur barry vous n'avez pas
changé depuis 1968 je vais voir avec les
pavés est en train de mettre le feu aux
voitures
alors que nous on veut des campagnes
tranquille on veut que les enfants
aillent à l'école
on veut qu'ils aient pas de pédophiles
n'ont pu ni sur les réseaux internet et
c'est ce que demandent tous les gens
avec ou de rouge que de rejet année coup
de rouge
je comprends pas question que de rouge
ouais je bois pas je ne fume pas jamais
bu jamais fumé avant et c'est pour ça
alors mes chers bien servir dernier coup
de bluff et reviens y monte mais c'est
terrible je fais des coups de fusil ça
secret défense dans les coups de blues
y'en a pas vous n'êtes jamais de coup de
blues non c'est formidable jacques nom
des gens qui ont jamais de coup de blues
c'est pas moi je peux pas répondre parce
que chaque fois
le fait d'être fliqué sans arrêt comme
ça moi je trouve ça insupportable
j'aime pas la police quoi moi c'est
comme ça même si un avis ces femmes
avides you parce que jackie chan pas non
plus des gangsters
j'aime pas non plus les mafiosi génial
en plus tout ça mais à un moment donné
où il ya collision quoi il ya collusion
plutôt que collision il ya collision
avec moi en tout cas j'ai jamais pu
appeler les flics quand j'avais à régler
un problème j'ai été voir le mec j'ai
parlé si c'était vraiment grave
ils sont jamais déplacés jamais et la
fois que je me suis trouvé dans des
commissariats en garde à vue où tout
j'ai vu des choses atroces et
dégueulasse mais profondément sous le
coup de la loi avec des gens qui étaient
sous le couvert de l'ordre de leurs
képis ray des tas de choses humiliantes
profondément salle quand on était avec
l'histoire du dal
il y avait 50 cars de flics pas des gens
comme vous pas des les gendarmes correct
d'accord poli propre sur eux et on les
paye c'est nous qui les payons quoi il
ya un moment donné j'ai demandé un flic
quand j'étais en garde à vue jeudi mais
vous n'êtes pas gardiens de la paix une
non monsieur je suis fonctionnaire de
police attend c'est quoi ça gardiens de
la paix pour moi ça voulait dire quelque
chose mais fonctionnaires de police va
te faire voir à quoi va te faire voir
pas mal en single
[Musique]
hop j'attends de la fin terrible du
dernier coup alors derniers coups de
pédales c'était quand les derniers coups
vraiment c'était hier ah ouais on vous
entraîner tous ces beaux c'était bien ah
oui au fait combien de kilomètres par
jour
oui des jours où je fais pas grand enfin
une heure de piste c'est très fatigant
par exemple donc
quand je fais une heure de piste je fais
un entraînement soutenu et bonne humeur
en fait 45 km vous oui non pas tous les
jours en gros quoi dépend ce qu'on les
met dans le bain co va faire beaucoup
plus et si mais bon jouer hier je me
suis baladée 2h quadri core et quand ils
débarquent ils additionnent le dernier
coup dur les contrôles 1,13 emmerder par
des contrôles un dernier coup de foudre
dernier coup de foudre votre mari il ya
longtemps quand même là je parle avouent
chercher cherchez pas dans ce sens là
non non jours c'est un coup de foudre de
quelque chose qui m'a plu c'est en force
que vous pensiez pas un mec en fait vous
êtes pur c'est bien dernier coup de
gueule
vous êtes un peu râler les réputations
là moi je trouve charmante mais on
m'avait dit elle un peu rallongé
l'avenir non dernier coup de gueule bar
au téléphone un contre qui quand tous
ces gens qui vous répondent de façon un
personnel qui peuvent pas que il regarde
sur l'ordinateur on entend les
techniques comme ça et puis qu ils sont
à trois milieux devenu quoi enfin bon
c'est rien n'avance quoi on a des
répondeurs et puis on attend et on
recommence on m'a quand même qu'on
craint qu'elle quand même qu'on ferait
moi je suis pas des réservations d
tgv les attentes de caunes dernier coup
de fil l'année coup de fil dernier coup
d'oeil à dorine dernier coup de fil me
souviens c'est à mon neveu pour dire que
j'arrivais à paris avant d'en découdre
aux derniers coups de rouge
oui s'il n'ya pas très longtemps ça
c'est pas tous les jours quoi ah oui
dernier coup de rouge c'était il ya
quelques jours
ah ouais vous devez pas du vin tous les
jours non dernier coup de bluff là
maintenant sur le pinard ah non dernier
coup de blues
dernier coup de blues yeah yeah pourquoi
air inter à l'eau d'un et coudre ah oui
aussi
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
que la bonne foi de ses amis des yeux
ses ennemis bon j'ai dû nathalie dernier
coup j'adore j'adore ce temps la fin
c'est absolument pas ce qui m'attend non
monsieur dernier coup je vous demander
par exemple le dernier coup de tête
facile non c'est pas facile un dernier
coup de tête
qu'est ce que j'ai fait à une fringue
une voiture une un mec un mec non c'est
pas nul à danser mais non mais faut
c'est prendre le temps pour recevoir les
lions se classant par la truck j'avais
acheté je sais pas moi même temps que tu
as mangé un truc que quelque chose
bah j'ai vu un très bon whisky un match
ou une épilation c'est le point
d'interrogation
non je dis c'est que je retrouve des
voitures et à me couper les cheveux tout
ça
c'est bien et c'était 3 heures du mat et
je trouvais que c'était un soulagement
bienvenu chez nous et donc je m entends
dire et tu avais vu non un truc à lui
c'est van sant final c'est à dire que de
temps en temps vous prenez j'ai pas une
cuite mais vous oubliez pas mal et elle
vous explique le lendemain matin je suis
comme neuf
oui vous êtes bien la seule personne que
je connais qui est neuf après une cuite
mois donc là vous venez de répondre à la
première question c'est un dernier coup
de tête vous êtes coupé les cheveux
donc on peut passer tranquillement la
deuxième dernier coup de coeur
vous êtes un cadeau olivier non c'est
non abonnés à mon avis est un dernier
coup de foudre
les bières
[Musique]
tu vois contrat ouais bien des coups de
fil bien et coups de fil c'est et à
olemps je suis pas dire ça pour quoi non
parce qu'il va s'énerver ou du bien
d'entendre ça parce que j'ai dit dans
mon lui dit pas olivier tu peux aller
chercher une bière dans le frigo
stoppait non non non bien et coups de
fil c'était ces têtes avec à la vous est
vanté un truc parce que boutef c'est
bien les gonzesses à monteux c'est parce
que c'est incroyable j'étais dedans je
suis dans le bain oui avec mon téléphone
portable à côté toujours et je fais
toujours des trucs l'oreillette je suis
tombé dans le bain c'est abominable et
je parle et m'appellent quelqu'un chez
les mecs ils sont beaux minable ah oui
comment savoir pratique peut-être taille
puis je veux olivier qui attend c'est
qui au téléphone tu passes et un copain
s'est énervé et j'ai mal agi mais qui
sont jaloux je crois c'est normal quand
on est une fille comme vous content
qu'on y tiennent attendait c'est normal
des choses
dernier coup de rouge c'est quoi un coup
de rouge du var olhao du vin non je peux
pas parce que j'ai les dents très pour
eux pour eux et donc si je bois du vin
rouge pour iliad
donc j'avais les temps poreux serre si
vous buvez guerre mondiale deviennent
rouges non crise après le bac ou 10
minutes
ma bulle et du vin blanc c'est ce que je
fais seul j'étais à courchevel il ya
deux semaines et une vie d'enfer olivier
est allé faire les soirées un peu
mondaine et moi je prie j'ai pris une
bouteille de vin rouge magnifique avec
une assiette de fromage comme ça et ça
et la télévision
fantastique les dans grease tout seul
c'est vraiment moi je pense quand même
que les pales
bien les coups de soleil il ya très
longtemps
tu mens plus le soleil je mets de l'auto
pendant parce que le soleil ça me fait
dit vous voyez là oui regarde pas c'est
là où j'oublie de m dos de l'écran tout
âge et là il ya quelques voilà alors que
là et là et à rien elle a donc elle a
pris le sommet mais elle la gare
découvrir ces gentillesses à une chanson
ça c'est une chanson ça c'est une
chanson elle a pris le soleil
l'excédent est la garder c'est le
prochain album tu sûr tu vas le faire je
tournais avec la face b au toit
majorettes heures c'est une mesure issue
c'est nul on la doit y est tombé
amoureux ça j'adore et du plateau de
fromages tout ça a déjà un point commun
ouais on aime le fromage et le bain j'ai
pas mal
dernier coup de blues au tout le temps
mais bon tout le temps j'arrive à dormir
le soir
donc je suis insomniaque et donc sa
salle est plus rare du sang s'est figé
mais je pense que ça développe le fanta
inui hallucinante
donc quand on est obligé de se lever
alors qu'on adore mes trois ans on
aurait voulu dormir 8 6 duos matin c'est
très très dur vous n'arrivez pas à
dormir
dieu est dieu ce qui tombe dans ma tête
et je n'arrive pas je voulais pas
prendre le somnifère vous êtes con ici
j'apprends à vous en prenez à prendre
mais mais le matin on n'est pas bien non
plus maya des trucs nouveaux maintenant
qui dure que trois heures dans ton corps
donc c'est bon ce qui n'arrive pas à
s'endormir
c'est pas pour ceux qui se réveillent la
nuit donc je prends cela mais c'est vrai
que comme tout le monde j'ai c'est de ne
pas en prend tous les soirs mais je sens
qu'on s'en va arriver je me dis ce soir
je sens que ça devient après on focalise
en voilà à vous avez eu la même chose
non mais je vous comprends tellement
bien c'est bien d'un déjà je suis en
parfaite empathie avec l'umih la
dernière question rituelle a dit
cévennes ce dernier coup de rein c'était
il ya sept ans
heureusement fiori est là pour traduire
merci dix jours les jours tu vas dernier
coup de bluff le bouillon dernier cobra
je suis à londres depuis bouillant à
voir mais c'est vrai que j'arrive que ce
matin et les prions au la la la la la la
la la
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
dernier coup de coeur dernier coup de
coeur coups de coeur c'est chez moi
maman retour et ce que j'ai fais
vraiment ça ouais j'ai regardé beaucoup
voilà dans les coups de poing dans les
coups de poing là je peux pas dire coup
de poing ce sujet glisse c'est une luge
en plus parce que si c'est vrai alors
c'est vraiment un accident c'est ça
bientôt ils aiment la bourre pif et la
nana qui vérifiaient sont pas là les
coups de foudre d'année coup de foudre
dans les coups de foudre c'est sur ce
que vous dites ou non ne vous inquiétez
pas dans les coups de foudre belle
écoute foot j'ai cessé mes filles quoi
il faut je suis j'ai ma fille qui a 4
ans dès fois me me fais moi rhône est
grave coiffer mois aux nîmois et la
maman connaît les pédales on a un coup
de foudre nom du géant vie des fois
quand on embarque à l'école j'ai envie
que ça te revient si leur vie en 4e
revient pour virement l'année va
chercher la bouffe est quoi un dernier
coup de rouge
dernier coup de roue ça fait 3 enfin
vous avez arrêté de boire
oui mais quoi que les bleus n'ont pas de
boulot même pas à opérer plus que je
suis je suis je pense que je suis devenu
un petit peu méchant quand est ce que
quand on boit beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
un moment où les nerfs le joker vous
l'avez dit il faut savoir il faut savoir
vous l'avez dit khaled dernier coup de
bluff là maintenant là maintenant je
suis bluffé la dalle et coups de blues
dany tristesse dans les coups de blues
dans les coups de blues
passé récent vous avez un mauvais un
coup de blues d'un coup de blues quand
on tape à la porte à lui si pour les
aime pas là vous donner un conseil à
tous les jeunes chanteurs et on vous dit
payez vos impôts
non mais c'est vrai mais quand on trouve
que déjà pour leur donne des chats kaki
qui reviennent et après tu t'agites des
majorations encaissé après is it on va
lui c'est ça c'est vos dernières
questions
dernier coup de rein vicié
[Musique]
[Rires]
eh bien dernier coup de tête à partir en
belgique comme ça d'un jour en danse
était sépare paris non plus mais bon ça
fait bizarre quand même de quitter une
ville dé loin en belgique le transport
de tous les soucis les j'allais vite sur
un dernier coup de coeur il ya 11 ans
quand même en jeu et ma femme donc ces
derniers vrai coup de coeur
après on a des coups de coeur ou tuer
les jours des gens sur des chaussures
des événements le vrai dernier coup de
coeur qui dure c'est frédéric pas dire
toujours oui c'est fort
la connaît toujours pas les coups de
poing dans les coups de poing j'ai de
faire un jeu travaux un truc c'était à
l'époque où je faisais était lésée
braille toi tu te fais un jour j'étais
arrivé avec la gueule complètement
déformés je m'étais fait déchirer la
tronche dans une bagarre et touche tu
avais dit que je m'étais fait choper
dans le métro avec ma femme j'ai
vraiment et que j'avais voulu défendre
ma femme parce que j'avais pas osé de
dire la vérité je peux te le dire
maintenant
en fait j'étais allé dans une soirée les
potes et savez est terminée en baston
générale les mecs avaient dit du mal de
moi et tu m'avais défendu mais c'est ça
voilà
je sais rien
la shdm en mêlée mais vachement de
lecture il n'est pas question maintenant
tu fais ce métier il pas question d'une
bagarre qui va être dit voyons donc
j'avais pas aux hits avouer que donc je
vous dirais je vous ai dit tu m'avais
pas cru photo éric surlendemain croire
ce que j'en dis là j'arrive à la fiche
vous pouvez me poser la question que
vous voulez la question la question que
vous avez le choix devant ensuite j'ai
une question que tous les spectateurs se
pose mode être parce qu'ils peuvent se
poser quand il regarde combien tu as de
nuces avec les années tu sais ça change
c'est dans télé 7 jours nous amuse non
non et acheta vraiment vraiment vraiment
52 enfants dont judith pose une question
et thierry 06 toujours emmerdé avec ces
trucs là la question j'aimerais tourner
vous avez une idée vous quittent l'ap
quelqu'un peut me fils aîné des as que
tu aimes bien les nus est ce que tu as
toujours les nuits blanches
oui maintenant pas chez les bleus c'est
pour travailler c'est plus pour sortir
ce que tu te fout de notre gueule
dernier coup de foudre abbas et le we
dernier coup de foudre bâtir le scénario
de la vérité de ce conflit paix avant de
recevoir vraiment une suite enseignant
n'oblige et on a un devoir y ait de ce
film parce qu'on lui doit tant eto'o
puis on l'a terminé on s'est tous
appelés pour la trouver vraiment à ma
dernier coup de gueule hier dans jeudi
chassées
je passais souple et je donne beaucoup
très coléreuse son époux serre dans une
radio
ils m'ont fait chier j'ai quitté le
plateau et en plus j'ai eu tort traîné
toute l'équipe je leur dis venez on se
casse qui sont aux derniers coups de
bluff dernier coup de bluff c'est pour
avoir un rôle dans un film j'ai fait
croire à lambert wilson que j'étais
engagé dans le même film que lui
ouais parce que je n'arrivais pas à
rencontrer la médiatrice brigitte roy et
priori il voulait pas de moi et j'ai je
recroise l'emblème ai dit je joue dans
le film j'ai moi aussi
aussi génial il appelle à riga trice et
qui m'a appelé après mehdi météo ça veut
dire quoi on joue pas dans mon film jima
ça tient qu'à toi allemand rencontré m'a
donné voilà il a appris le poker avec la
vérité un dernier coup de barre en ce
moment pour rich tkc nettoie la salle
parce que ça fait un mois et demi que je
suis donc en tournée que frédéric encel
a pas pu y aller pas eu l'occasion de
venir à une vis à vis pas à la fan bruno
solo elle a une vie les sculpteurs et
artistes beaucoup de travail en ce
moment en belgique il fait la pole temps
elle préfère celle de jouer vers
bourgeois demain oh [__] c'est que
j'ai la banane aulas
[Applaudissements]
vous savez qu'on ne bouge pas pendant un
jingle
à
on
bien c'est l'interview derniers coups
des quatre bus là pour ça oui c'est ça
bon vous êtes prêt faudel de quoi bas
l'interview l'interview dernier coup est
parti dernier coup dur mort de charles
trenet c'est un parent à vous dernier
coup de tête
foot au foot je m'y arrête j'ai marqué
un but on cherche des gens qui veulent
prendre offert ses partisans si vous
savez marquée des charges déduites ont
déjà là encore je cherche des buts je
suis de melior bastille
comment avez-vous simplement ils
marquent contre leur camp je leur
apprends d'aller dans les travers
ils ont ils cherchent des buteurs c'est
payé 300 millions l'an dernier coup de
coeur alors des coups de coeur c'est un
album ne peut dire qui bah oui julien
clerc ah ouais si j'étais elle est bien
celle là j'aime bien le fait mieux que
toi faudel on se concentre dernier coup
de poing et mouchan nous violons jamais
si c'est pas crédible quand je fais ça
tu es une patate
ouais je sais pas j'ai jamais fait un
dernier coup de folie tanner coup de
folie
je cherchais une porsche j'ai acheté une
maison à ma maman bien dernier coup de
foudre
coup de foudre séverine ferrer et vous
la regretter un peu ça va faire un nom
dernier coup de fil coup de fil
j'ai demandé l'adresse de ton studio
ouais voilà voilà dernier coup de rouge
c'est un petrus 82 aulas est très
souvent mais quand ils boivent c'est du
bon dernier coup de bluff sang du christ
dernier coup de bluff
bon là j'ai dû moi j'ai blessé
maman parce que je l'invité à manger un
couscous le dimanche et et je vais dire
au fait j'ai oublié j'ai inventé des
coups de froid
coup de froid ici dans le studio parce
qu'il car il faut mettre de bulles comme
accusera qui vient aux césars avec sa
wii avec ton forfait
dernier coup de blues coup de blues
quand j'ai quitté séverine fini dernier
coup de rein c'était hier
hier mais elle a un petit garçon
maintenant on est fatigué on embauchera
part dans le qinghai
bien vous avez déjà un peu romane c'est
super ça va vous êtes très sage mes
jambes
non mais quand ma fille est pas là c'est
plus simple de pas bouger parce qu'il il
entraîne les autres en fait c'est comme
à l'école tu as des mecs qui entraîne
les autres situées dernier coup dur tout
le panel ouais c'est quand serge est
parti dans les coups de bol j'avais 10
mars un génie dans les coups de tête ont
su pendant longtemps d'ailleurs sont en
asie la wii ah oui c'est vrai importants
du vietnam ou pas pour toujours quand
même moi je vais tuer partir dans les
baie d'halong avec l'al aventure chez
l'habitant cela remet ça dans les coups
de coeur aulas tel courant dans les
coups de poing sur les murs ah oui ah
oui c'est à ce moment-là pense qu'astana
n'a pas levé 8 janet je m'étais découvre
ça m'est arrivé je lui ai dit si tu
continues à l'école comme ça c'est coup
de boule maintenant là c'est pas là coup
de poing ses coups de boule dernier coup
de foudre
serge dans les coups de gueule bien des
coups de fil me lie à des coups de bluff
du dernier coup de blues
un dernier coup de masse était très
récemment et là c'est en train de
continuer un petit coup de blues
dernier coup de rein couvent ah oui
c'est cependant mais c'est vrai nom mais
c'est mais je sais mais vous n'avez pas
la remplacer
non comment puis je sais pas quoi chez
mon coeur et puis si mon coeur me dit
regarde bien les maquis vous drague
quand même oui mais c'est pas mon
problème
ou toujours une sainte
oh non pas du tout je suis doit d'être
une simple ça c'est clair
mais bon je vous dis ce qui se passe
bien la direccte jamais l'endroit
l'interview dernier coup vous êtes prête
[Applaudissements]
du
nadja dernier coup dur mamie coup dur
avec mon fils ce matin qu'est-ce qu'il a
fait s'est cogné la tête donnait avec
lui ouais t'as quel âge je comptais
dormi avec ma femme dort toujours avec
mon fils pour s'assurer en scène il a 18
ans non mais ça va il a deux ans le papa
il n'est pas et pas un peu vénère ne pas
dormir avec maman non non il sympa la
question se pose pas
voilà mon avis est une gaffe c'est pour
savoir
c'est une ouverture ça n'a rien d'une
bio dans les coups de coeur à mon fils
ah oui il ya eu depuis le fils il prend
peut-être beaucoup de place à la fin
faut pas vous fixez trop sur ce bébé non
plus on n'a pas beaucoup quand même
et j'ai la chance de l'avoir c'est
vraiment une force et nous ça me procure
beaucoup confie je vais recevoir des
emails moi c'est incroyable a dit même
jeu des bleus va pas bien dernier coup
de poing non c'était alors 2 du tournage
d'un clip en fait il y avait le champion
d'europe de kung fu et voilà on a fait
des petites allées d'accord ces
professionnels d'aller coup de foudre
vernet coup de foudre avant cette fois
hier soir
bon déjà catherine pimkie univers est
très intéressant
vous connaissez catherine barma très
bien très bien
dernier coup de gueule d'un et coups de
gueule
ah oui avec la directrice de la crèche
de l'office parce que j'ai récupéré mon
fils avec qui de morsures à 100 et ça
m'a pas plu je suis normal la gelée
oui par un autre bébé enfin un autre
enfant quoi de mort sur mon écran
pour faire quand il ya trop d'enfants
avec avec pas mal de références est pas
normal a fait bien fait d'aller coup de
fil d'années foudre rouge n'ont jamais
jamais est musulmane et non ce n'est pas
le droit c'est déjà l'odeur jamais cessé
de bien cette religion musulmane
d'ailleurs sur le droit de fumer des
pétards non bâchés cépages jamais sinon
plus là si j'ai des risques accrus
belgium est d'accord mais je veux dire
dans les vapes assumer sont enfin c'est
pas bien qu'elles sont sont joints avec
lui dit diamant sur la dent ah bon tu
peux pas c'est joli dans les coups de
soleil et longtemps il a longtemps dans
les coups de bol 1 252 mètres carrés à
3000 francs par bon nombre
voyez-les ou non je rigole mais c'est du
berry n'est pas passée vous là nous et
non non pas de ça chez nous avant ça se
fait pas avec va nous et les gens auront
plus d'appartements inquiété dans le
comité de soutien de la noce qui est
très drôle c'est le jour nous a tous
réunis pour nous remercier il a dit et
surtout ne comptait absolument pas sur
moi pour obtenir quoi que ce soit nous a
très très bien qu'il a fait si gérard
fait dans mon bureau
j'espère qu'ils rompent père qu'il veut
pas j'espère qu'il le pense vraiment
avec l'amf est évidemment que d'être
remercié voilà monsieur triaud très
locaux le crois oui oui je crois qu'il
l'a dit qu'il est temps de faire c'est
mignon merde il est nul
là les coups de blues hier soir que ce
qui s'est passé je la fais tout seul le
soir etc et à nice by any cif et 2007
tout seul alors à la question cruciale
dernier coup de rein est ce matin à la
salle de gym
parce que je fais beaucoup de sport je
m'entraîne énormément comme j'ai eu pas
mal de coups durs la une porto rico il
ya eu droit si on va vous faire
l'interview
dernier coup en ébauche pendant le
jingle
[Musique]
enfin pendant le jingle et c'est une
rebelle guinée mois dernier coup d'oeil
à porto rico
porto rico dans les coups de foudre il
ya longtemps en tête avec un total de
4,4 aussi une affaire qui dure dans les
coups de gueule ses fidèles des coups de
fil dernier coup de filet c'était pas le
courrier picard tout à l'heure à
l'aéroport
pourquoi les 3e aéroport qui veulent
installer des tic est incroyable c'est
lui qui dirigeait le pays j'aime bien je
voudrais maintenant tuerait parce que je
changerais tellement de choses ah bon
feriez quoi par exemple si vous étiez
premier ministre la première décision
vous prendriez j'ai déjà je serai plus
là bourse qui mènerait le monde
ah ouais ça déjà reste que c'est
l'argent qui mène le monde en ce moment
et moi je suis révolté de voir de plus
en plus de misère et ça qui me révolte
aussi c'est sophie thalmann
quand je pense que le gagner des fois
dans une en une heure ce que les pauvres
caissières des grandes surfaces gagné en
un mois
et moi je trouve que devrait avoir honte
de dire des choses comme ça pour pour
simplement faire peu délicat chez à
sourire vous êtes pour la taxe tobin
geneviève attaques des poids la taxe
tobin
notre prono non non tout ça l'euro ça
marrant ça me fait des dix ça me hérisse
le poil de penser à lui ronge juste
quand tu t'habitues anovo france
[Applaudissements]
dernier coup de rouge avec le nom avec
s'était pas gêné pas ton dans les coups
de bluff
elle a dit je paye sincèrement non
souvent c'est geneviève oui qu'est-ce
qui ronge les robes après minuit et ce
qui remet tout dans les années moi je
moi une fois que c'est fini comme ça il
faut quelqu'un remballe qu'est-ce qui
remballe il va acheter du lait ce qui
s'y passe c'est moi qu'est ce qui
conduit pourvu que j'ai encore la santé
pour continuer geneviève bitume sa jolie
dernier coup de chapeau
[Rires]
j'entendais bien toutes les deux
j'entends bien avec tous les oui c'est
ça qui est bizarre c'est moche mais
c'est vrai qu'à 4 6 2 a coûté le ghana
des méchants hommes d'orange
jamais jamais élevé on se concentre
dernier coup de rein à joker commandes
faire une petit matin du dernier coup et
là nous est prête
en la bouche pendant toute une gamme
le bouche par dans les dunes galles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dernier coup dur dernier coup dur c'est
d'avoir d'avoir vu moyens des animaux
dernier coup de tête
d'avoir refusé un concert 1 uniquement
parce que le répertoire n'était pas moi
ouais dans les coups de coeur le dernier
concert parce que chaque fois dans un
conseil en communication émotionnelle
qui s'établit et c'est ça qui sauvent en
fait il ya des coups de poing pas encore
dernier coup de folie
tulu dernier coup de foudre
la france entière est suspendu a volé la
france entière est amoureuse de vous et
veut savoir
non non en fait le dernier coup de
foudre c'était pour une oeuvre way we
dernier coup de gueule
avec la maison de disque l'année
dernière ouais dans les coups de pub ici
dans les coups de fil cette nuit à quai
avec l'homme que j'aime dans les coudes
rouge
mais coup de rouge
non je n'aime pas trop le vin un bon nom
buvez quoi vélo 101 reagan en 3d quoi
comme drogue
ma drogue c'est le cancer c'est
l'adrénaline à la peine dans les coups
de soleil
il ya trop longtemps ya six ans ah ouais
ouais cet été vous parlez un peu au
soleil quand même bien pourquoi je mens
pas le temps non autant ça se prend
remarquez on a tous 24 heures dans la
journée
c'était l'été vous pourriez partir un
petit peu vous vous accordez side merci
non mais c'est vrai dernier coup de
barre le mois dernier à paris ouais
ouais ouais incapable depuis ce pari oui
vous avez des concerts à ce moment là
non je sais comment c'est grâce à maman
vous avez aller les émissions de
télévision mais pas des cancers bien des
coups de chapeau au prêtre de notre
paroisse dans les coups de froid
l'indifférence dans les coups de blues
moi j'ai le blues en avance oui ah bon
j'ai le blues pour tout ce qui ne s'est
pas encore produit allez un dernier coup
de rein il n'y a pas si longtemps il ya
une semaine mais j'ai deux boxeurs
donc on va faire une interview dernier
qu c'est normal en bouche à bouche
dans le qinghai on ne bouge pas pendant
le tigre
brian dernier coup de tête là ce soir
ouais dernier coup de coeur le spot que
je viens de faire
ouais pour l'éducation nationale pour le
respect pour les jeunes c'est vrai
dernier coup de poing le 8 octobre à
paris pendant et depuis il n'y a pas eu
de coup de poing non juste le ring comme
j'ai dit sur le 3 1 dans les coups de
folie
de monter sur un ring ouais je pense que
c'est une folie bien des coups de foudre
ont d'abord un joker joker un joker donc
c'est la personne à côté qui répond
c'est la loi ici je sais
jim un dernier coup de foot vous venir
dans votre émission
mais si j'arrêtais le rapport comme
annonce tout va bien maintenant vous ai
enfin rencontrer très bien et toi les
good food et le dit busch annonçons la
vie c'est bizarre oui c'est bizarre
c'est bizarre bizarre et bien bien bien
des coups de gueule l'agent la situation
ah bon ouais m'a dit de passer gens vont
passer
un conte samedi les deux sujets discutés
moi ouais gtg judy respect monsieur
l'agent respecter bien placé pour dire
ça bouge
madani reprise ne s'en va le combat
on va faire une interview dernier qu on
ne bouge pas pendant l'été une gare
[Applaudissements]
très bien tu peux bouger la whey dernier
coup de coeur dernier coup de coeur
tourcoing ouais ouais j'aime bien cette
vue moi c'est jean pascal
je trouve que c'est un garçon qui a
plein de talent et d'émotion
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dernier coup de poing dans les coups de
poing j'ai vu chez qui le nul mais ta
coupe point un mec là pendant un match
ouais et j'ai trouvé ça extraordinaire
mois à bouli dans les loges à m'énerver
que son casque l'année coup de folie un
aspirateur 1500 arrêté a été vraiment de
la tude ah si peut-être des filtres à
café que j'ai j'ai claqué au mot dans
les sandales deux sont peut-être en
euros ouais ça fait ça à peu près
dernier coup de foudre
je pense que ce moment pour mais j'avais
été chercher mon courrier chez moi et en
fait dans la cage d'escalier donc je
descends et j'ai croisé ma mère et on
sait se regarder tout ça tu en voilà
j'ai un peu craqué ça s'est arrangé avec
ta mère tu vois la coke dans les coups
de gueule enfin et coups de gueule b à
l'aspirateur
après je fais engueuler quand le dernier
coup de pub mais c'était avant
d'aspirateur ah non moi c'est quand j'ai
dit omar tiens regarde la bague et une
crêpe au fromage qui t'appelle
vers les coups de fil j'ai appelé le
rythme le mec pour qu'il fasse marcher
l'aspirateur d'acteurs non moi c'est
j'ai appelé mon père pour lui expliquer
par ottawa mme lanier coudre ou je te
demande pas tu vois pas toi non non
jamais jamais ah non moi je trouve que
sans alcool la fête est plus folle tiens
c'est ma devise
allez tous bien dernier coup de soleil
c'est pas marrant c'est bien
je tente et c'est vraiment toi moi c'est
quand je me lève le matin que je tourne
la tête et je vois qu est-ce qu il
évoquait ce qui les musées français et
les bronzés dernier coup de bol et petit
déjeuner mois du riz dernier coup de mou
ce dernier coup de blues baisse et là
maintenant parce que je sais qu'on n'ira
jamais chez fogiel quoi dernier cobra
découdra il ya deux ans j'ai donné un
remake
[Applaudissements]
non
dernier coup de tête dernier coup de
tête il ya trente secondes je prenne la
tête contre le mur dans les coups de
coeur je pense que j'ai mis tout le
temps je tombe raide dingue de plein de
choses de tous devant leurs coups de
poing coups de poing bbc qui est venu
hier matin chez moi je les athées dans
les coups de foudre
c'est un trip bien les coutumes avait
tout à l'heure à etienne il ya deux
minutes là avant l'indicateur est
touchée dit franchement était d'avoir
peur d'en découdre rouge bat aussi elle
a beaucoup de points dans les coups de
soleil
jean-louis je prends le soleil ne bronze
pas ouais j'ai un jour pour aller faire
des photos de nu la dent lui là que le
père de mes enfants
on est parti très très long à l'île
maurice où ça bronze paraît-il j'étais
comme ça j'ai les coups de soleil
et puis je ne faisais pas un don juan a
fait tout max factor l'un des coups de
blues en fait c'est tout le temps
forcément
dans les coups droits il ya longtemps
[Musique]
à vous me décevez de plus en plus
franchement assez bien et là qui bouge
pas par le djing ça c'est très bien en
garde sent bien les coups de tête mais
je suis dans mes coups de coeur mon
nouveau chéri mais magnifique marie les
grands il est moyen bruns les yeux
marron très mignon très gentil s'appelle
thierry je peux tirer sexuellement est
ce qu'il est comme tous les tirs et a
ajouté je ne vous ai pas testé mon cher
donc je ne sais pas si vous n'avez pas
voulu en même temps alors
excusez moi alors n'ayez pas de la
malveillance mai dernier coup de poing
je ne sais pas j'ai mis un coup de poing
sur la table il ya pas très longtemps
non mais vraiment très fort mort m'a
fâché je te téléphone on m'a bien énervé
on reçoit des coups de folie ça faisait
longtemps que j'étais pas sorti j'ai
fait vraiment une mega mega nuits
blanches effet deux jours non-stop son
avenir donc voilà on va dire c'est ça
mon peu trop me passe
il ya des coups de blues il ya une
semaine
pourquoi j'ai pas des fois je me remets
un petit peu en question je suis je
salue la couleur des médias non non non
j'ai je me remets en question des fois
je me demande si j'analyse un peu ma vie
je suis un peu le bilan de tout ça même
si je n'ai que 22 ans
il est des fois j'ai des petits coups de
cafard comme tout le monde mais c est
mon signe astrologique qui veut ça aussi
en balance son trait voilà vous
regrettez fabrice des fois pas du tout
bas du jour puis de médical en amour
c'est comme ça c'est où j'aime et puis
quand c'est fini je passe à autre chose
d'ailleurs je profite de
ici pour dire qu'il faut arrêté de m'en
parler parce qu'il est avec une autre
femme et elle commence à en avoir marre
de moi d'accord donc faut plus parler
des qui remercia chéri d'accord dernier
coup de boule ou moules couchettes
ouais j'aime fut jamais sympa on imagine
des trucs en tête dans les coups de
reins ça c'est un discret bon pourquoi
autant entendu tout à l'heure
vu que vous êtes blessé robert pirès
vous comprendrez qu'on vous fasse une
interview dernier coup
[Applaudissements]
bien les coups de tête je suis pas
méchant donc presque pas dans le m ouais
dernier coup de coeur dernier coup de
coeur le dernier cadeau que j'ai pu
offrir à ma femme pour son anniversaire
c'est quoi c'est un c'est un collier en
forme de coeur un diamant un diamant
j'aurais dû épouser un footballeur mais
je suis quand dernier coup de folie il
montre cher oui oui quand même acquis
pour moi parce que merde bien des coups
de pub
bachand points on attend y avait brel et
les fin du mois c'est pas les fin du
mois ne disposions que tu prends un
shampooing pour un dernier coup de fil
c'était un ami pour savoir où j'allais
manger ce soir
ouais vous appelait encore hey les mecs
lamanon ouais ouais je suis en relation
et sylvain wiltord
qu'est ce qui dit sylvain non ça va ils
vont bien il faut pas s'en inquiéter un
joueur tout le monde s'inquiète le
commandement mais très inquiète elle a
commencé à paniquer un peu et qu'il faut
il faut attendre simplement pas temps de
la finale tu crois non non
dernier coup de rouge je vois pas les
coups de bluff
là maintenant il boit là maintenant un
dernier coup de bol la coupe dernier
coup de blues français légal d'ouverture
de la coupe du monde difficile c'était
quoi le score 1-0 pour le sénégal dur
dur et pas super bon bout on gagnera
coiffer dernier coup de rein hier soir
avec les amis et tout ça non
sa survie
bien alors que c'est toujours vers vous
êtes acteur de films d'action en même
temps un homme de coups on vient de le
voir dans tous ses différentes activités
et avec sophie a indiqué aussi donc
maintenant on va faire interne ou
dernier coup
[Musique]
qu'est ce que l'on meure dernier coup de
tête
dernier coup de tête partir en bateau ou
en grèce
à cg ou en grèce dans toute la gamme
nikon non une soirée mykonos j'étais
avec ma femme ces bons coups de coeur je
t'ai vu mais pareil qu'une femme coupée
par les pales un dernier coup de coeur
mais s'il fait bronzer 20 minutes sur le
ventre les boîtes et deux semaines je
veux dire à toute l'ue jamais qu'on
parle de ça prouvait que sur levante là
bas alors dernier coup de coeur
enfin bien les coups de gueule dernier
coup de gueule je suis quelqu'un
d'extrêmement calme un patient mais je
suis pas un gueulard du tout c'est à
dire je m'adapte je te ferai novartis
dix derniers coups de beats et là où
partir se fichent de fresnes à mort
sinon il valait vers grossier un dernier
coup de fil à leurs derniers coups de
fil
vrai ou le vrai dernier coup de fil que
tableau après un dernier coup de fil à
samuel et aux producteurs de
janis et john pour savoir comment ça se
passait en arrive vignon où ils sont en
ce moment et ça se passe bien et ça se
passe à salé bois il ya des gens sur les
marches d'escalier tout baigne c'est
génial dernier coup de rouge passé il ya
deux mois et demi et dénis co2 rejeté il
ya deux mois et demi dans les coups de
bluff
c'est la terrible sur le roux la fin
dernier coup de soleil
j'adore j'adore le soleil de se présente
comme entité mais je me mets jamais au
soleil d'accord ça madame je mets de la
crème et en plus je rougis donc c'est
bizarre et un écran au total par exemple
je sais qu'au sol est quand même dans
même way et à l'ombre à l'ombre dernier
coup de bol dernier coup de bol d'avoir
rencontré samuel et d'avoir ses toiles
au niveau de ma carrière au niveau de ma
vie sophie dahl et coups de blues bien
écoute blues quand quand je buvais
beaucoup et que ces refuges ça me
faisait du mal à ma vie ouais ils se
mettaient les lélés les cassettes de
vingt cinq normales puis ta j'aurais pas
dû faire ce qui finit bien les coups de
cul ouais non non d'en découdre à autre
chose yann un peu enfin
makonda mieux poudre à bagnac ya quatre
jours parce que je suis arrivé il ya
trois jours que tu veux pas jeter un
week-end à part dont on comprend
[Musique]
allez ce dernier coup de boule et non on
était pas de football mais enfin bien
les coups de tête coup de tête voulait
dire moi je sais pas être là ce soir par
exemple
ouais c'est bien je moi c'est plutôt
vers les coups de pub ça peut-être
ensuite mais si on fait plaisir
dernier coup de tête ça serait de dents
partie avec philippe lellouche après
l'émission ça ce serait un sacré coup de
tête mais bon je te remercie pourquoi
coûtait tient non ça peut être un coup
de ça peut arriver
bah oui du hasard c'est là qu'il a
rencontré vanessa les amis c'est vrai
dernier coup de poing dans une vitre
j'étais énervé pour la tertiaire rien
elle était là d'un des coups de folie
j'ai pas faire cette pièce de théâtre
ouais voilà quoi m habillée comme ça
habillée comme ça un dernier coup de
folie
non pas trop non non non mettre des
porte jarretelles voilà abap abap solo
jean qui veut dire non et demi pourrait
pour les sincères à sa famille fait
attention à ce genre de truc gspc en
direct alterné on attend direct qui
arrive à signaler je pense que ça donc
donc voilà même temps c'est par un coup
de folie je le fais régulièrement donc
continuer d'en parler c'est sur un sujet
mais quand tu dis souvent c'est à dire
je suis en affaires comme ça pour le fun
on les porte jarretelles un père c'est
plus rare il fait froid
dernier coup de foudre alice dernier
coup de foudre est mon amour et notre
amoureux s'étaient encore chuté il ya un
nom aux ses 10 ans qui se termine tout
ça dernier coup de gueule dans le taxi
qui m'a amené ici là pourquoi m'ont-ils
entendez vous a dit l'audimat de 15,01
il nous a pris la tête
pourquoi parce que ils voulaient pas
nous amener là où on allait il voulait
aller ailleurs forcé non je vais en
espagne coup de fil à votre assistante
ah ouais vous avez des quoi bein ça tout
va bien je suis dans le taxi d'un coup
de rouge abeilles à 2,9 à voilà je vous
laisse tranquille
oui oui tu tirais shopping oui ça fait
quand même une petite bouteille
d'ailleurs c'est vrai oui parce que ça
serait quand même
voilà vous pouvez faire l'amour agen
quand même bien sûr dernier coup de
bluff ou coup de bluff mais à bernard
murat voilà qui m'engage et danse à pied
du mur avec le soleil on pas de coups de
souris dans les coups de bol attention
ça se rapproche tous les jours vous
n'avez que deux eaux
rarement ah bon oui je te prendrai mon
album la star
de vous
dans les buts que abaya yahia quoi il ya
5 heures la cua bah oui oui qu'est-ce
qui lui ont valu de casino elle a
confondu
ah non non mais nous on a mal compris
s'écoute plus couture en sculptant des
bleus moi j'ai compris comment il manque
un je ne pensais pas les religieux tape
deux ans avant de rentrer en scène un
dernier coup de cul c'est quoi c'est ça
la question
pour vous c'est quoi pour vous un
dernier coup de cul c'est quoi pour vous
un dernier coup de cul vous allez me
demander quand je les us et dans les
coups de gueule
cet après midi mais oui s'expliquer au
bout quoi c'est quoi les truculents
parce que c'est ce que c'est un coup de
cul c'est quand tu sais quand tu
cherches
c'était bon découdra musulmans des coups
de cul y a même redonné un coup de cul
[Musique]
dernier coup de tête dernier coup de
tête dans mon dernier match de football
chez pas content à camp sara monte parce
que j'ai une sciatique en ce moment donc
sa femme ont bien joué au ballon bien
mes coups de coeur et coups de coeur
pour moi forme actuelle qui je viens
d'avoir un enfant la sciatique donc il
parlait ça vient de là aussi bien les
coups de poing ça devait être en même
temps que le coup de tête
un dernier coup de folie je me suis
acheté un appartement
ah ouais quand même ah ouais ouais j'ai
vécu 37 300 de nice tu vois là on me
donnait j'ai eu l'occasion d'acheter un
appart servir des deux frères étaient ou
là bas je suis dont 9,2 c'est bien c'est
plus chic and not one via les gens du
9-3 qui vont siffler mais c'est pas très
lourd
tu prends les quais pour un flash
étaient assemblés et après versailles
après je sais pas
voire peut-être le têt dernier coup de
foudre moi je te les dites à l'heure ce
flash c'est ma femme bien les coups de
gueule tarrier coup de gueule je crois
que c'est écrit dans c'est mal barré
ouais là des coups de fil
tout à l'heure on est potes là dans la
neige ouais pour lui dire je passe là
ton des missions d'espionnage
ils sont bons on n'a pas l'occasion de
passer souvent à la télé donc c'est ça
leur fait plaisir quand on est là
dernier coup de soleil
la dernière fois je suis allé en
vacances mais t'as vu le montant il est
pas très bon et donc moi dès qu'il faut
un rayon de soleil c'est le pain est
directe il ya plus de soleil dans le 9 2
que dans les trois ça dépend d'altitude
à la kryte habite dernier coup de bol et
coup de bol je suis rentré deuxième
l'eurotop fait passer dans le football
dans les coups de blues
j'ai perdu les divx a doit être celui-là
un dernier coup de rein à ya pas
longtemps non plus malgré la sciatique
on se débrouille pour être sur un t2
inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou